you were watching cold fusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
it's no secret that artificial
intelligence is progressing rapidly it
seems like every couple of weeks there's
an unexpected development that takes
people by surprise it's starting to
become clear that we're near the start
of a new era that will include
artificial intelligence those people
that aren't paying attention are likely
to be taken aback by the things that are
going to be possible in a few years some
voices have spoken out about the dangers
and need for safety measures that must
go along with developing powerful AI one
of the loudest voices of concern was
that of Elon Musk in a strange twist
eelain's non profit artificial
intelligence startup which is called
open AI has just achieved a pretty
remarkable feat in this video we'll take
a look at what's going on so what's the
background story every year the game
developer valve hosts a competition for
expert players of the game dota 2 a
popular online multiplayer game the
competition hosts professional players
from all around the world all fighting
for a twenty four million dollar grand
prize this year there was a special
guest competitor who wasn't human it was
an AI trained by the engineers of Elon
Musk's startup open AI when put up
one-on-one against one of the world's
best players of dota 2 a crowd favorite
Dendi the artificial intelligence one
even a year ago nobody was sure if this
kind of thing was possible Dendi was
surprised that an AI could outplay a
human he said that the AI quote felt
like a human but a little like something
else
end quote this feat was achieved with
just two weeks of real-time learning by
the AI the engineers stated that during
this training period it accumulated
lifetimes of experience they also state
that the rules of dota are so
complicated that if you just wrote down
pre-programmed rules and programmed some
code to follow it the end result
wouldn't even be as good as an average
player the artificial intelligence was
trained from scratch with no knowledge
of the game it played against itself
over and over again until it had
mastered the game
how on earth does a computer learn to
play dota yeah so this boat is quite
unlike any what you've seen before so
we've coached it to learn just from
playing areas itself so we didn't hard
code in any strategy we didn't have it
learned from human experts it's just
from the very beginning it just keeps
playing it's a copy of itself it starts
from complete randomness and then it
makes very small improvements and
eventually reaches the pro level these
are pro players these are human brains
so you just telling me this robot has
failed so many times it's actually
better than professional dota players
it's played for really lifetimes of
experience and it's great so many games
of dota
it's explored many different strategies
learn to be learn to exploit other
people who beat and it's just played far
more into the strategy space than any
human has musk is hailing this
achievement as the first time that
artificial intelligence has been able to
beat professionals in competitive
eSports with eSports being considered
for the 2024 Olympics this is certainly
interesting so this actually isn't the
first notable achievement by open AI
they've actually done some pretty cool
stuff in the past the company actually
invented a method where humans can
interact with a robotic AI and teach it
just like he would a human here's how it
works first a human wears a VR headset
does a task and the robot watches and
then imitates the task in real-time
without ever having done it before in
this case it's learning how to stack
some Lego blocks that task sounds very
simple for a human but it's actually
extremely hard for a machine to do this
the AI manages to do this by having its
visual neural network trained on a large
set of images of what blocks and
simulated environments could look like
this first visual neural network then
feeds the data to another neural network
called the imitation Network after this
training and after just one a single
original demonstration of what to do the
robot can now stack blocks even with
different colored blocks placed in
different positions every time this
means that the robot has to and does
perform different actions to the
scenarios that it's already seen the end
goal is to create an AI that can adapt
to new and unpredictable environments
okay now back to open a eyes recent
achievement Elon has tweeted that his
feat of beating some of the best dota
players in the world with an AI is a
task much more complicated than chess or
the board game go now I'm not so sure
that I agree with Elon statement that an
eSport is more complicated than go chess
yes definitely
but go perhaps not some state that go is
the most brilliant game ever made go is
a 3000 year old Chinese board game in
which an AI called alphago from the
company deepmind recently beat the world
champion in a series of playoffs this
event was held the biggest moment in
artificial intelligence not expected for
another decade he is deepmind CEO Dennis
Hasset us talking about some of the
complexity of go now thing about go is
that he only has two rules I could teach
you the game in five minutes but it
leads to incredible complexity it's
probably the most elegant game that
mankind has ever devised what happens in
Asia and career in Japan or in China is
if you show promise in the game of go of
at the age of sort of five or six or
seven you get taken out of Normal School
and get put into go school where you
study go 12 hours a day seven days a
week with your peers who are also trying
to become professional go players this
has taken really seriously and it's been
like this for hundreds of years now one
way to illustrate the complexity of the
game is that there are not more board
configurations in the game of go than
there are atoms in the universe so
there's no way that you can solve this
game through brute force calculation
it's much too complex even if you took
all the compute power in the world and
you ran it for a million years that
wouldn't be enough compute power to
calculate all the variations in go if
children are literally pulled out of
their school to spend half of their
lives training to master this game
I can't really just dismiss it and say
that dota 2 is more complicated or very
again this could depend on your
definition of complicated but it's just
something to think about on the topic of
deepmind I imagine that some of you
would be interested in a few GC updates
about what deepmind's alphago was up to
also what has humanity learned from that
moment when the go world champion was
defeated by an artificial intelligence
well while playing it's winning match
against the go champion alphago played
some very strange moves they ended up
giving it the advantage to win the match
to be clear in over 3,000 years of
humans studying and playing go who have
never thought of playing the way that
alphago did alphago's moves have now
been used in go schools to train
students and expand their way of
thinking about how to play the game and
further to this deep mayan plans on
using the alphago algorithm for more
general-purpose functions as it shows
great promise in its ability to learn
and I think of AI is this incredibly
powerful tool that will augment human
ingenuity and unlock our true potential
in fact one way you can think about AI
and indeed alphago is like AI think of
it as analogous to the Hubble telescope
a kind of ultimate tool to explore the
universe of course for go players
alphago was allowing them to explore
their universe of the game of go and I
think there are many other domains in
the real world that suffer from this
kind of combinatorial explosion that go
has now obviously as I said at the
beginning we test our systems on games
because they're the most convenient way
to develop our AI algorithms but
obviously ultimately we're not
interested in just being good at games
we want to translate those algorithms
into the real world and be useful and
make huge impact on real world
situations and one reason we could
believe we can do that is because we're
building general-purpose learning
systems they're not being handcrafted
for the gate further that first aid like
chess they've actually we've actually
built we believe general-purpose
algorithms that could be taken from the
games that we test them on and apply to
real world
and we're applying these to all sorts of
other areas healthcare robotics and even
optimizing data centers so a variation
of alphago we took over a last summer
and we applied it to Google's data
centers and we managed to save 15% of
the power that was used in those data
centers by controlling the cooling
systems more efficiently so there you
have it as always is some very
interesting times in the field of
artificial intelligence
it seems that artificial intelligence
playing games would be a great way to
enable it to learn but further to this
the knowledge learned could be applied
in other fields making the act of
playing games much more important than
order first seem both deep mind and open
AI are going with this strategy so
what's your view on the story are you at
all surprised by this or is this all
just normal to you by now if you're a
subscriber of this channel I'm sure
you're pretty used to it anyway that's
the end of the video thanks so much for
watching if you've just stumbled across
this channel feel free to subscribe this
has been - go go you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll see you again soon
for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
you